- Deux tiers d'eau,
une cuillère à soupe de jus,
et aprèet aprèet aprèet après çe
parce que c'est moins cher
ce jus...
- Celia coupe désormais
ses jus avec de l'eau,
question de les maximiser.
Ce mélange lui permet de faire
quelques économies, petites
mais essentielles, son budget
étant particulièrement serré.
Avec un revenu annuel de
30 000 $ et une hypothèque
à payer seule, couvrir
les dépenses courantes estde pl.
CELIA ROJAS-VIGER
- Je ne peux pas acheter
les choses que j'étais habituée
d'acheter. Avoir un petit peu
de viande, un petit peu
de produits laitiers...
Et les poissons,
on n'y pense pas.
- Même la quantité
de médicaments est réduite
au minimum, malgré une récente
opératio
- Au lieu de les prendre
quatre fois par jour,
voir si la douleur,
on est capable de l'endurer
un peu plus, donc ça va
être diminué.
- Louise Cordeau fait elle aussi
d'importantes concessions
ces temps-ci. Plus de 50 %
de ses revenus, qui totalisent
20 000 $ par année, servent à
payer son loyer. Pour y arriver
dans le contexte inflationniste,
elle réduit ses portions.
LOUISE CORDEAU
- Si j'achète deu
de poulet, je fais quatre repas
avec, je ne fais plus juste
deux repas.
- Avec les coûts du logement
et de l'alimentation
qui augmentent, Louise
se plus duse plus duse plus dust
pour se faire plaisir.
- Tout ce qui est activités
culturelles, c'est certain
que je n'ai plus les moyens,
les sorties au restaurant...
- Selon ce planificateur
financier, les aînés,
comme Celia et Lou
sont parmi les premières
victimes de l'inflation.
MARTIN DUPRAS,
planificateur financier
- À la retraite, généralement,
on ne contrôle plus vraiment
les revenus, les dépenses
seulement. En travaillant,
on peut changer d'emploi,
on peut avoir un autre emploi,
travailler plus fort à
la limite. Donc, j'ai un certain
ôle sur mes revenus.
À la retraite, souvent,
mes revenus vont être fixes.
- D'après les données de
la FADOQ, les individus
qui reçoctement
la pension de la sécurité
de la vieillesse et
le supplément de revenu garanti
du fédéral touchent 19 950 $
e. 50 % dee. 50 % dee. 50 % dees
et plus ont des revenus de moins
de 27 000 $ et plus de
que soit bonifiée de 10 %
la prestation de la sécurité
de la vieillesse pour
les Canadiens de 65 à 74 an
comme elle l'a été pour
les plus de 75 ans, et souhaite
ceci du provincial...
GISÈLE TASSÉ-GOODMAN,
présidente, Réseau FADOQ
- Ce qu'on propose, c'est
de mettre en place soit
une subvention ou encore
une couverture par le biais
de la Régie de l'assurance
médicaments du Québec, la RAMQ,
pour assurer les soins dentaires
ou encore l'achat de lunettes
prescrites ou encore
areils auditifs.
Vous savez que ce sont
des dépenses bien importantes
que bien des aînés
- Mais d'ici à ce que
de telles demandes soient
entendues, Celia souhaite
de vie
et celles des autres aînés
soient radicalement améliorées
puisqu'elle n'a plus
d'alternatives.
- Quoi couper de p